And you've also shown a lot of things from behind the scenes.
So, you had Gagavision on Youtube and GaGaInfo from Twitter would like to know,...
..."Please, could you bring back Gagavision? We miss it so much. PS: We love you and we're so proud!"
I love Gagavision. They were these little films that I was doing,...
...back when I first began touring. But I actually just got so busy that...
...it was really difficult to have a camera on my face. You will never see me do reality television.
It will never, don't even ask, it will never happen.
It will never happen.
It's just, I'm not that kind of person.
My whole life is a performance piece, so I don't need to have my picture taken...
...to feel that I'm in a moment of art.
But the good news is, as I'm planning the Born This Way Ball,...
...I have been speaking to Terry Richardson who's this really amazing photographer. He wanted to...
...film some of the "making of" process of what we're doing. So,...
...I'm hoping we can resurrect the Gagavision videos...
...for the creation of the new tour. So, you guys can creatively...
...be more connected to how I make things.
That would be great.